it lands on his nose he said it was the
most horrifying pain he lost his vision
it all came back later but he went black
in the nose that's why you may not want
to go to the Amazon jungle
hey GQ I'm Les Stroud also known as
survivor man and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up the movie jungle let us say if
you knew the whole story of Yossi
Ginsburg and and his time in the jungle
it just seemed like everything went
wrong for him that's to stop it right
there first of all the concept of
somebody sleeping on a raft like that
when you're in the jungle when you're
traveling like that you're kind of ready
for a nap at any moment of the day so
him being out of it on his back on the
raft totally realistic
I'm a whitewater instructor so I've been
down many rivers that look just like
that you come to a lot of bends if you
have no experience to see the signs on
the river you have no idea what's coming
right around that bend it could be a
calm serene pool where you can pull out
and sit on a sand beach or it could be a
hundred and fifty foot waterfall I know
what you're thinking
no no you'd hear the waterfall not true
when you're coming from the top
waterfalls are not audible when you're
coming to the top of them at the bottom
sure they're deafening but at the top
you don't even see them the trained eye
will see this you'll see a flat line and
if you see little Spitz jumping up
behind that flat line in the water
that's definitely a sheer drop-off you
want to watch for that so these guys see
that little pinch up there who knows
what's next there's a lot of good
realism in this movie I think now I know
Josi very well I actually wrote a a
commentary on his book so the movie had
to deal with something that actually
happened in history they had to get it
right and they had Yossi there as a
consultant and this is why so much about
this movie nails it when it comes to
what the jungles really like
so now you're on a raft you're going
down a huge set of Rapids and what you
see in terms of escape routes and places
that you can get out to go by like this
real fast so it's not a matter of oh
look there's a beach over there let's
just paddle over to it now you see it
you're on it and you're past it all
within a split second it's really really
tough to get out of a set of Rapids when
you're in the middle let alone being on
a raft which you can't steer you can't
maneuver very well you're at the mercy
of the river at this point
okay so right there you see Daniel
Radcliffe's hand and the other guy's
hand too on the paddle I'm happy to see
this actually they're showing signs of a
good paddler I'll grab my guitar show
you what I mean let's pretend that this
guitar is actually a paddle and here's
how you'll see people paddling down the
river their top hand will be like this
and their bottom hands like that and
they're probably wrong true way to
properly hold a paddle in a whitewater
situation is your top hand must always
be on the top of the paddle and then you
paddle and you paddle now if you want to
turn the canoe there's a way to do it
called a J stroke where you paddle you
Bend and you kind of pivot out here's
the catch here's how you know when
someone's getting a paddle stroke right
if they're attempting to do that term of
the J stroke their thumb is pointing
down and away from them if they do this
stroke and they go like this and then
pry we call that the goon stroke because
the thumb is pointing at the goon
alright
suffice to just say these boys were
taught well before shooting this scene
because they're getting a pal Stokes
right
wherever they shot that scene as they
come to the opening there and you see
the rapids and then it goes out of
camera left there well I guarantee you
that right after camera left was
probably just a big flat pool then then
it's like pull them out and go okay cut
next scene and that's the one of the
things I wanted to watch out for here
was how often you can spot the stunt
double because they're in some real
serious water here and only an
experienced River rescue technician
whitewater paddler will know what to do
in water like that there are a hundred
and fifty movies with paddling scenes
and they get it all wrong this is not
one of them so good on them
Oh No if you notice when he grabs Kevin
that's like I think that's the
character's name in it they go down
they're headed towards a big rock in the
middle like a torpedo so they throw
themselves so they go headfirst in Iraq
completely wrong in fact there is a real
technique and a real method to being in
a set of Rapids when you're outside of
your canoe your boat your raft and in
this situation that I mean they had to
basically prepare themselves for it and
they didn't they went headfirst stupid
in all whitewater situations you want to
basically think about always feet first
and you you do this with your arms you
always do this with your arms so what
are you doing you're slowing yourself
down that's how you safely go down a set
of Rapids always want to be feet first
so that your feet take the shock of the
rocks and the branches the kind of speed
you're going to experience is it's it's
just on the edge of scary this is a lot
different than then say the bottom part
of Niagara Falls that would be just like
a rocket in this situation every Rock
every tree every bend in the river
creates a water blockage which creates a
slower area of water
this is absolutely probably the most
terrifying place to be it's because the
water that is coming down on that rock
and on their bodies is like the force of
somebody in a car with their bumper
against your legs and they're pushing on
the accelerator it's an intense amount
of pressure and they're trapped on this
rock so why can't they just climb up on
it because the water is so powerful it
makes it very difficult in a situation
like that and it's probably one of the
most fearful times of my life so this is
a powerful scene and they've done it
well when you're a whitewater paddler
you hit a rock like that you're supposed
to hit it bow first that's the front of
the canoe and glance off it right or
left if you take that rock sideways we
it's called breaching on the rock and a
canoe or a kayak will hit that rock
sideways and will wrap around it and
once it's there once it's wrapped around
that rock with all the force of all that
water pushing on it you can't get that
canoe off without some very specific
skills that you can incorporate there
are ways to do it but you need a lot of
rope and you need a lot of help
the camera the drone comes down and we
see this long shot of the guys stuck on
the rock and then you see there what's
they're looking at which is that Canyon
with all the frothy water you remember
I'm also a film editor I'm a filmmaker
so I'm noticing a change just in the in
the colorizing but I'm wondering if they
used some kind of CGI or green-screen in
a situation like that
drop didn't break apart they're still
hanging on to it and remember on that
raft and on those two guys is enough
power enough intensity of water that
it's like somebody's holding them with a
car with their foot on the gas pedal
so kevin is looking back at the shore on
the other side and he's going I can make
it this guy was dubious as in any event
and and you're supposed to know the
water and the shoreline if you are
someone who travels these rivers and I
would have known looking at that there
is no way that I can swim across to that
just looking at the intent of the power
and the speed of the water depth of the
water cannot get across there so this is
basically an act of desperation at this
point
you don't have a lot of options in a
situation like that especially for the
second man for y'all see who's stuck
there I think the thought that Kevin
could take the machete and make a make a
rope and throw it to y'all see that's
about it - last ditch effort you should
have taken the machete and swam with it
you know kind of hold it like this and
swim with it anything but say throw it
to me after I get over there
love that just that terrified look of
Daniel Radcliffe as you'll see looking
ahead and that's all you see when you're
in a situation like that you don't see
anything pretty you just see frothing
white water black water gray water and
it's very scary just to see that you're
stuck in the middle of a washing machine
and you're sure you're going to drown by
the way drowning one of the most painful
ways to die
you're not supposed to do that you're
supposed to do a backwards swimming to
have your feet in front of you there
therefore bouncing off rocks you paddle
backward to slow yourself down and the
way to do that is you can angle yourself
like a bird so you want to go to River
left just drop your right arm down a bit
and back paddle this way and that is how
you get yourself out of a set of Rapids
paddling straight forward with the front
crawl and the likelihood of you smashing
your forehead onto a rock is very high
it and very very dangerous the whole
thing about trying to swim in a set of
Rapids or get out of a set of Rapids
have you dunked in them it's all about
entrapment
if you try to stand up in a set of
Rapids as you think okay I'm good to go
you should never do that unless you can
feel the bottom and it feels like you're
in maybe six inches of water and here's
what happens now you're standing up did
you step in between the rocks the
water's coming this way you get pushed
over you snap your legs right there and
now you're flopping like this with your
head under the water and that's how you
see your last day it can be very scary I
have fallen like that I have never
snapped my legs and very quickly have to
kind of hold on and roll over and it's
terrifying absolutely terrifying
I'm glad that when he went under the
water they just did it for effect they
did they did a whole camera turn right
but what we call that in whitewater
paddling is a washing machine
so when you get dunked and you're under
the water and the water is all circle
it's basically eyes in the washing
machine it's very hard to get out of
that the only way to really get out is
to dive to the bottom and spit yourself
out but try to have the presence of mind
to do something like that
oh just even watching this is intense
next up predator
[Music]
I know aren't he's strong but this
strong it's kind of stretching it a
little bit those trees are pretty
powerful so normally you're gonna need
like like a bulldozer to get that tree
to bend over like that but you know
these guys are really strong
[Music]
okay so jungle vines yeah I gotta say it
it works it's I've been blown away at
times by how strong and how readily
accessible vines are in the jungle and
the way you can use them in you really
rarely have to make rope out of
something in a jungle often the vines
are just there and they they suffice
really well so this is good
the downside of what those guys are
doing right now is that they are
stirring up a ton of insects many of
which will be poisonous from Hornets
nests to bullet ant nests when you start
messing with the jungle and gathering
all these vines you're stirring all of
that up and they didn't really play off
of that but that is what's going on you
really think this boy's got to see our
tripwires
maybe it can see this a group survival
situation and often there is the
Negative Nancy the the person who is
just like going yeah come on this isn't
gonna work
that's the person you need to give a job
to do and that's kind of what Artie's
character did right here when I first
started in survival there were a lot of
things that they seemed a little geeky
at first you know but once you get into
it you realize that they have their
basis in just really great skills
Curie's Joe can calm them Boy Scout
Bulls but sometimes it's that Boy Scout
book that'll save your life
[Music]
wow that is a messy tie job on that rope
you'd think that guys with these kinds
of skills would know how to properly
make lashings and that is not all I can
say is that's not the proper way when it
comes to making trip wires for dead
falls and snares that's a whole field in
itself you've got to learn your knots
and your rope or you know how to utilize
vines
it starts with knife use so now you know
how to carve things and make little
things then you've got you have to
understand the creatures you're going
after there's a lot involved with
knowing how to make an animal trap
deadfall is a way of capturing an animal
that you might want to eat and you can
do that by getting a large object
setting up a triggering mechanism and
when that trigger is tripped by the
animal the rock or the log falls down
kills the animal you got yourself dinner
snare is basically taking a rope or a
wire and you need to put it in the area
where an animal is traveling through
there's a lot involved in trapping the
thing about building anything in any
survival situation is it's made better
with gear if you don't have even a knife
to work with trees and wood and just
about any material just your hands it
can be done but it takes forever and it
kind of takes a village I think what I
loved about the predator films were that
in the end you realized it was a highly
intelligent being and that you know the
reason was going to be the thing that
enabled you to capture it so in the real
world we go after animals based on
instinct almost entirely on instinct but
sometimes they think
[Music]
my guess is that this was not actually
shot on a Hollywood lot but that it was
shot somewhere they could get to there's
definitely realism in where they are
these trees are real but then they're
adding in atmosphere with all of the fog
that that's the thing that always got to
me is watching a jungle scene and then
seeing that the filmmaker decided he
needed to add in atmosphere sometimes
it's just always overdone it's like you
know what the area is already dramatic
enough it's powerful I was thought that
was Survivorman I never tried to make
something look more dramatic than it was
because it already was inherently
dramatic the network one time wanting me
to start to fake Survivorman by writing
in some more dangerous scenes and and I
and I remember saying so let me get this
straight
you're telling me that a guy me alone in
the Amazon jungle for seven days without
food without water no survival gear
filming myself is not dramatic enough
for you ya know and so I never did never
rode in drama because the jungles
already dramatic okay next up king of
the lost world
basically that's a fogger machine that
they've got down on the ground there
somewhere for that
mist blowing by I'm in the jungle a lot
of times I can't say I've seen mist that
thick blowing past my feet in the middle
of the trees maybe out by the river but
not in the middle of the trees so we're
getting into some this is gonna be
cheesy let's just face it okay so I
really like to know how many people
would see a spider web and ask what is
this moss with a question mark oh oh I
don't know where to begin with this
there's so much that's off here the
largest insects that you'll find in any
jungle you know get to be you know about
like this still big and scary when it
you know some of them are benign and not
not dangerous at all but they're you
know like cockroaches for example so
there are some pretty massive insects
out there just nothing nothing like this
spider this is not a high budget
so the leaders check him see if he's
alright he just got thrown out of a tree
by a spider the size of a car and he's
already completely wrapped in something
and that's the leaders call check him
and see if he's all right whatever
chemicals are in that spider to eat away
flesh notice how nice and clean the
eyeball is though you'd think that the
chemicals from the spider that
completely dissolved the flesh this
quickly would have done something to the
eyeball as well but you know you had to
have that buy the thing about poisonous
creatures it's a little known fact that
the closer you are to the equator the
more intense let's say the more toxic
the poison actually is let's make sure
we get the terms correct here poisonous
venomous the snake is venomous a spider
is venomous they can inject the venom
into you poison is something you ingest
so we often just conflate those terms
and say oh it's a it's a poison of such
such that's not poisonous it's venomous
let's get that right
the problem with being bitten or stung
by just about anything is that the
likelihood that you will have what you
need to take care of that venom that's
gone into your system is pretty close to
nil you can carry a snake you know
anti-venom but then you have to get
bitten by that snake that you carry the
anti-venom for you have to administer it
perfectly or you can kill the person and
if you're out in the jungle most of the
time you're just gonna have to try and
hopefully live through it in some cases
you won't here's the thing about my time
in
close proximity to anything that can
attack me sting me bite me nothing has
ever happened to me but mostly it's
because when I'm in those situations I'm
really cautious for example there's a
difference here and how you step on or
over a log now in Canada I might step
over a log why well if I step up on it
at the breaks I could snap an ankle
however in the Amazon jungle I don't do
that because if you step over a log
that's where snakes like to lie you
stand on the log and then you sort of
jump off of it and that is a safer way
to make sure you don't get bitten by a
venomous snake in the Amazon jungle
yeah because spiders hiss okay that's
not completely untrue actually there are
creatures little creepy crawlies that
make hissing sounds and worse and it can
be very scary especially at night here's
a spider story for you I was in the
Amazon jungle and the indigenous guaraní
native man named Tomo and he's sitting
by his fire and he's got a six foot long
poker stick there's a spider size of my
hand over there and he's poking this
spider and the spider jumps up and lands
right on his nose and bites the second
it lands on his nose he said it was the
most horrifying pain he lost his vision
it all came back later but he went black
in the nose that's why you may not want
to go to the Amazon jungle
[Music]
oh yeah that's just so great that is a
big big spider I will say there are more
species of poisonous creatures in
Australia but the intensity of them in
the Amazon jungle is is stronger it's
palpable
okay she's not actually screaming boy
this is some bad editing why is it
always the girl that has to fall on
screen why don't they have like a guy
follows and I'm not talking about like
like the ditzy guy like why don't they
have like the hero fall and scream just
once
[Music]
but once again I will say that there are
better movies if you want to see some
realism in the jungle thanks everybody
for watching these clips with me now
stay tuned for part 2 of jungle survival
scenes